German Defense Minister Annegret Crump
Karin Bauer has ordered the partial
dissolution of Germany's elite ksk
commandos following reports of
right-wing extremism in their ranks
reports say the unit which specializes
in anti-terror and rescue operations may
face a major reorganisation and up to 70
of its 1,400 personnel could be cut
military investigators announced this
year that they suspected 20 KSK
personnel of holding extreme right
attitudes media reports quote the
Defense Minister is saying the unit has
a toxic leadership culture and cannot
continue to exist in its present form
for more on this let's bring in our
political correspondent Simon young
Simon a toxic leadership culture within
Germany's elite commando how serious is
this well I think it is it is pretty
serious the German Defense Minister has
just been speaking about this she says
most of Germany's soldiers and service
personnel are fully committed to you
know the German Constitution and
democracy but there have been a growing
number of worrying cases of people with
right-wing far-right views cropping up
he cross the military in isolated cases
and particularly in this
KSK special forces unit so that's why
the Defense Minister now is saying well
you won't we've had an investigation and
we're going to take drastic action as
you mentioned they're suspending special
forces missions and you know ending
aspects of what this particular unit has
been doing because they say they want to
really get on top of the problem of
right-wing your sympathies within
Germany's military Simon's stay with us
because this is the elite this is an
elite commando unit we are talking about
but the Bundeswehr in general has been
under criticism for right-wing extremism
our reporters have talked to a former
soldier let's have a look
he enlisted in the Bundeswehr in 2015
then 18 years old he was proud to serve
and motivated but shortly after the
three-month basic training he tells us
his view of his comrades-in-arms changed
someone made a joke about Jews long
noses things like that then someone else
said what's that mate you're saying
there are still Jews I thought would be
eradicated them all have another go at
that another time one of the guys was
telling us how he and his brother forced
some refugees out to a lake where he
lived and went after them with sticks I
butted in and said you didn't really say
that or do that
did you miss dying in Michigan how Kozak
just has to talk it's to please
Dorcas Act or as okema anti-semitic
racist and right-wing extremist remarks
were tolerated or at least ignored the
former soldier says criticism from new
recruits was not welcomed so he remained
silent you're in the massive pressure to
fit in with the others not to stand out
if you do you get thrown out that's what
the system is like you said Africa fine
dust esteem indistict a hierarchical
system of ignoring sentiments and active
silencing of criticism in the ranks that
is also what florium faff a retired
major experienced accepts a leap when
they know from personal experience that
their superiors make them break the law
and cover up crimes when they're forced
into doing these things then of course
they conclude that these are not
isolated cases that is coming from the
highest levels and also reaches into the
realm of politics particularly
Germany's opposition Green Party has
been tackling the issue for years and
problem dismissal yeah it's a constant
problem that I've been trying to tackle
on the parliamentary defense committee
servicemen and women complain that they
can't speak out because it would damage
their career we've seen a string of
whistle blows exposing right-wing
extremism in the Army in the end they've
been forced to leave in the bundesliga
gongsan
the issue has repeatedly made headlines
in recent years numerous cases of
right-wing extremists in the ranks have
come to light
critics say the problem has not yet been
recognized as structural and that's up
to now no appropriate measures have been
taken the co ruling Social Democrats
defend passed reforms three years ago we
brought in structural reforms to help
root out extremism still a backlog of
cases our awareness of the problem is
not new it's always been the joy on
tears of NIMH activism confronted with
the experiences of the former soldier
Germany's Defense Ministry said it
condemned anti-semitic xenophobic and
extremist behavior of any kind by
members of the army the defense minister
said anyone who remains silent is part
of the problem and is complicit the
ministry says it will now take steps to
tackle the issue the former soldier
eventually turned his back on the
Bundeswehr now he hopes that things will
finally change despite the bad
experiences he has a clear vision for
the German army and open and honest army
that looks after soldiers who speak out
when things are not right an army that
doesn't just get rid of soldiers who
break the mold enlist member clean down
if that happens he could even imagine
going back into the army one day Simon
Young is still with us
Simon the German Defense Minister just
held a press conference how exactly does
she want to tackle the issue of right
being extremism within the Bundeswehr
well one of the things I mentioned is
she's going to send a signal to the KSK
this elite force in particular that
things have to change and they have to
change soon that signal is going to
involve ending missions and you know
pulling out of current missions and
planned missions there seem to be only
about 30 KSK personnel at the moment in
the field in Afghanistan where they're
in a training mission that will continue
it seems but other field exercises and
training missions will not go ahead
they're also going to disband one of the
companies where it within the KSK which
has had particular problems also
bringing training within the KSK under
the authority of central military
control so a real tightening and the
German defense minister said if there
isn't an improvement in rooting out
right-wing extremism by the end of
October then further consequences may
have to be faced
Simon Young thank you very much for that
let's get more now we are joined by
Thomas wiegel's he is a journalist and
an author with a focus on the German
Bundeswehr thank you so much for joining
us we've just heard it there a toxic
leadership culture within Germany's
elite commando how serious is it I think
it's pretty serious
you mentioned already investigators from
the counterintelligence unit of the Army
are investigating this unit for at least
two or three years which is a major blow
to to the Armed Forces in itself
well actually the plans which will be
formally announced today include the
disbanding of a part of this
deep unit not the unit as a whole and
this means that the minister and the
ministry is trying to get to get rid of
those toxic parts of this unit without
disbanding the unit as a whole without
destroying the cap ability they need
let's talk a little bit more about
what's been going on in this unit
because we've been seeing a couple
incidents in recent years including Cos
Cob members allegedly throwing pig heads
and performing the nazi salute at a
party on another occasion we have
reports of large amounts of ammunition
and explosives disappearing how is this
possible well that's a question which
hasn't been really answered I think the
major point was in mid-may when police
searched the house of a sergeant major
of this unit and they found weapons they
found ammunition without explosives and
most of it came out of stocks of the
Bundeswehr which means that arriving
extremists had been able to put
ammunition and explosive on the side
obviously preparing for some kind of a
right-wing extremist actions and that's
that's a major concern you have elite
commandos trained in weapons trained in
ammunition and they have for the
personal use some explosives on the side
that's something no army can tolerate
and let's not forget you said it there
these are elite commandos the best of
the best what does this tell you that or
more broadly about the general state of
the Bundeswehr
and do you really think that you know
these restructurings that we've heard
announced can really tackle the issue of
right-wing extremism there well that
remains to be seen we have also have to
see that the head of the
counterintelligence unit this Monday for
the first time used the term right-wing
networks in the Armed Forces
so far this was always considered
officially at least as single cases now
the counterintelligence unit the
ministry is regarding this as
the network issue so they have to find
those networks they have to identify
right-wing extremists this is in the
active forces as well as with rather
West's they also have been reports and
the number of right-wing cases which is
under investigation has risen to 600 in
recent months now on the other hand
there isn't one hundred eighty thousand
men army which means it's still online a
number that's still reason for concern
Thomas waggled journalist thank you so
much for joining us with that
perspective my pleasure